vereine sind eine arktis und andere süße
beide werden einfach verrecken
vor einigen tagen habe ich bereits ein
video hochgeladen in dem wir uns einem
rätsel gestellt haben von wegen wer
stirbt zuerst und da dieses video vom
mega gut bei euch ankamen und alle
meinten hey luca du bist ja so blöd
macht doch mal bitte im zweiten teil
versuchen wir heute wieder ein heftiger
detektiv zu sein mit dem video zehn
spannende rätsel die nur die besten
detektive lösen
ich bin der beste detektiv marin
detektive sind echte genies sie müssen
nicht nur wahnsinnig scharf sonnig sein
sondern auch noch sehr gut gebildet ja
ich habe sie haben die einzigartige
fähigkeit ihre intelligenz mit ihrem
allgemeinwissen zu kombinieren und so
selbst die kniffligsten fragen zu
beantworten und auch die schwierigsten
rätsel zu lösen ja das war ich vor ein
paar jahren kommen wir zum rätsel auf
der nummer 10 auf einer raumstation gab
es einen überraschenden mordfall du hast
die leiche am morgen im lagerraum der
raumstation gefunden wo unter anderem
auch die astronauten anzüge aufbewahrt
werden sagte dass sie in ihrer kabine
auf der raumstation war und geschlafen
hat nix sagte dass er von außen
reparaturen an den solarzellen der
raumstation vorgenommen hat und jana
sagte dass ihr im cockpit der
raumstation saß und per funk mit den
mitarbeitern aus der kommandozentrale
gesprochen wer von den dreien hat
gelogen und ist der täter
also lauren hat geschlafen jana hat mit
den leuten auf der erde kommuniziert und
nick war im weltraum das heißt nick war
der einzige der einen astronauten anzug
an hatte und die leiche war ja dort wo
die astronauten anzüge aufbewahrt werden
detektiv ich sage es war nick der lügner
unter den dreien ist nicht wenn dann
tatsächlich für reparaturen die
raumstation verlassen hätte ja auch in
den lagerraum gehen müssen um sich einen
raumanzug zu hoya und hätte dort die
leiche gefunden
da er wirklich da gehört nunmal 9
stell dir vor du hast ein altes haus von
einem unbekannten alten großonkel von
dir grs war was ist das bitte für ein
scheiß haus in dem dunklen kellerraum
hast du dann drei geldsäcke gefunden in
einem der geldsäcke sind tatsächlich
eine million euro auf dem ersten satz
steht das geld ist nicht hier auf dem
zweiten satz steht ebenfalls das geld
ist nicht hier und auf dem dritten satz
steht das geld ist in dem zweiten von
diesen drei botschaften ist allerdings
nur eine war in welchem sack ist also
das geld
verstehe ich ja vorn und hinten nicht
also wir haben ein haus geerbt und haben
in diesem haus eine tür gefallen und
hinter der tür befinden sich diese drei
säcke mit den aufschriften das geld ist
nicht hier das geld ist nicht hier und
das geld ist in satz zwei ich würde
einfach alle drei säcke aufmachen
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es absolut
mich wenn das geld in sack 3 wäre dann
wären die ersten beiden aussagen richtig
wenn das geld im sack 2 wäre dann wäre
die aussage auf den dritten und auf dem
ersten entsprechend ist das geld in sat
1 so habe ich überhaupt nicht überlegt
auf der nummer 8 haben wir einen
supermarkt rätsel in einem supermarkt
gab es inzwischen mehrere fälle von
diebstahl der manager des ladens konnte
bisher nicht herausfinden wer der
ladendieb war januar 2017 okay april
2017 und juni 2017 welche der vier
personen ist des diebstahls schuld was
bei solchen das wissen also dass hier
ist überwachungs bild 1 wir haben hier
eine schwangere dame mit einem
einkaufswagen wir haben hier die dame
die eine tüte mit zwei äpfeln hat er
hier wirkt sich nach dem obst und sie
hat eine orange
ich habe keine ahnung was man das jetzt
sagen sollen dass jetzt das zweite bild
sie hat wieder ein orange sie hat zwei
äpfel die dame ist noch immer schwanger
hat einen einkaufswagen und er hat immer
noch seinen korb und hier im dritten
bild er hat er auch noch immer seinen
kopf sie doch über die orange sie ist
nicht zu sehen und sie hat immer noch
ein wagen und ist schwanger
ich habe gar keine ahnung ich würde
sagen das ist die schwangere dame ist
weil ich das geraten habe die richtige
antwort ist die schwangere frau mit dem
grünen oberteil ganz neues ich habe mir
nämlich erst gedacht dass man irgendwie
im januar 2017 sehen könnte okay sie
schwanger dann sieht man aber im april
sie ist nicht schwanger und dann sieht
man im juni also dem dritten bild das
sie wieder schwanger ist weil das hat ja
geheißen dass die die ganze zeit der
melone irgendwie darunter gehabt hätte
diese geklaut hatte aber ich glaube das
hat einen anderen grund über die monate
hinweg also über eine zeitspanne von
januar bis juni verändert sich ihr bauch
dementsprechend muss ihren
schwangerschaftsbauch zumindest in den
kamera aufnahmen von april und juni ein
kostüm sei
dann hatte ich ja doch recht kommen wir
zur nummer 7 ein sicherheitsbeamter
steht vor einem bankgebäude und
überprüft mit einem passwort code ob die
besucher auch in das gebäude
dazu sagt er den personen eine zahl wenn
sie die richtige zahl auf seine zahl
antworten dürfen sie ein trick bei der
ersten frau sagt der beamte die zahl
sieben daraufhin nennt die frau die zahl
sechs und gelangte das gebäude dem
nächsten mann sagt der beamte also die
zahl sechs und der mann sagt die zahl 5
und darf ein trägt dann kommt noch eine
person der beamte nennt die zahl 5 und
die person sagt die zahl 4 und tritt
herein bankräuber der die ganze
situation mitbekommen hat denkt sich
dass er mittlerweile den
offensichtlichen code durchschaut als er
vor den beamten tritt sagt dieser zu ihm
vier der räuber erwidert daraufhin
sofort wird er abgeführt und gelangt
wegen seines einbruchs versuches hinter
gitter
es ist nicht 3
vielleicht sieben weil hier sehr 76 54
und hier ist dann 65 47
und dann geht es wieder von vorne los
die gesuchte zahl ist immer die anzahl
von buchstaben die die zahl hat die der
beamte genannt hat
oh mein gott sehr klar wenn er sieben
sagt dann hat 76 buchstaben also dann
sagt er 66 hat fünf buchstaben wenn er
55 4 buchstaben und wenn er viel sagt
muss man halt auch viel sagen und das
wort 4 hat eben nicht drei sondern
ebenfalls vier buchstaben er da muss man
wirklich erstmal drauf kommen auf diesem
bild siehst du ein volles restaurant zur
abendstunde ohne dass es die anwesenden
wissen gibt es unter den
restaurantgästen eine person die
eigentlich ein alien ich glaube er weil
ich mein wer ist bitte so eine banane
erscheint noch nie gesehen zu haben wie
man eine banane isst und entfernt sich
somit als dass amy also ich würde
wirklich meisterdetektiv auf der nummer
fünf muss wieder ein passwort gelöst
werden als seine frau den pc nutzen
möchte versucht sie zuerst einige
naheliegende passwörter
allerdings hat sie nicht den richtigen
riecher und kriegt immer wieder fehler
mit ok dann bemerkt sie einen zettel am
monitor auf dem hinweise für das
passwort schon auf dem zettel steht
folgendes
oh mein gott okay das ist stark jetzt
weiter buchstaben dem wort april ist das
p der vierte buchstabe dem board bananen
ist das a der sechs buchstaben hier ist
das essen wenn man so weitermacht kommt
das wort passwort raus wer nutzt bitte
passwort als passwort die richtige
lösung ist ganz unkreativ passwort
kommen wir zur nummer vier eine
grundschullehrerin hat sich überlegt
ihre stunde mit der klasse mal anders zu
beginn okay sie gibt allen schülern eine
anweisen steht auf wenn ihr denkt dass
er dumm sein einer weide steht also ein
junge auf das bin ich darauf hin fragt
ihn die lehrerin ob er wirklich denkt
dass er dumm sie lautet die antwort des
jungen lehrern sagt haye steht auf wenn
ihr denkt dass ihr dummen seit und er
steht auf und die lehrerin fragt hey
denkst du dass du dumm ist dann muss er
eigentlich ja sagen ich kann nicht in
seinen kopf rein gucken also ich habe
wirklich überhaupt keine ahnung was er
sagt wenn ich nicht aufgestanden wäre
dann wären sie ja die einzige die stehen
würde das war doch keine rätsel zehn
spannende rätsel die nur die besten
detektive lösen also dieses rätsel war
wieder spannend noch irgendetwas für die
besten detektive nummer drei am rand des
waldes stößt er auf einmal auf ein feld
über das drei wege führen
der erste weg führt zu einem
gefährlichen sum der zweite weg führt zu
einem vampir schloss okay der dritte weg
wiederum führt zu einem aktiven vulkan
oder unkontrolliert lover von sich
sprecher der drei wege ist
wahrscheinlich der sicherste
ich würde ganz dumm behauptet einfach
mal sagen der weg in der mitte weil es
ist ja taghell und vampire sind ja
glaube ich nur in der nacht aktiv wie
sofern das überhaupt vom pier geben
sollte die richtige antwort ist weg
nummer zwei es sah der backpacker am
hellichten tag unterwegs ist und vampire
bekannt gleichermaßen nachtaktive
geschöpfe sind geht der das geringste
risiko ein wenn er den zweiten weg wählt
alter immer muss wirklich richtig blöd
denken da diese rätseln
ein reicher hausherr hat einen 100 euro
schein in eine schublade von sich
geliehen als er von seinem
geschäftstermin wieder kam bemerkte er
dass der 100 euro schein verschwunden
war okay er hatte drei verdächtige die
er daraufhin befragt er sein koch sagte
ich habe den geldschein unter das buch
auf dem schreibtisch getagt die putzfrau
sagte dass sie den schein in das buch
zwischen seite 1 und 2 getan
okay der dritte verdächtige der
elektriker sagte dass er gesehen hatte
wiederschein aus dem buch geschaut hat
so dass er ihn dann zwischen seite 2 und
3 getan okay die putzfrau wird
wahrscheinlich in das zimmer gegangen
sein und hätte halt alles geputzt hat in
die schublade gehabt und hätte gedacht
100 euro scheinen mich packte man lieber
zwischen seite 1 und 2 dann kommt der
elektriker an und sieht wie er daraus
hängt der schein und packt inzwischen
seite 2 und 3 und der kellner keine
ahnung warum er überhaupt in diesem
zimmer sein sollte also ich sage es war
der kellner wenn du wusstest dass der
dieb der elektriker ist dann hast du
einen punkt mehr der koch konnte es
nicht gewesen sein da die putzfrau das
geld unter dem buch gefunden hatte
ich dachte okay und zum schluss kommen
wir zur rätsel nummer 1 ein junge ist in
einer kochend heißen sandwüste und ein
anderer in einer eiskalten
schneelandschaft und beide haben nichts
außer einer chance
wer stirbt wahrscheinlich zuerst der
eine sind arktis und der andere süße
beide werden einfach verrecken wieder
mal so ganz bescheuert rätsel video
mäßig gedacht der rechte ist in einer
heißen landschaft und hat auch ganz
wenig an was man halt hat denn man
irgendwie am strand ist oder irgendwo wo
es halt heißes der linke allerdings ist
schon in einer kalten landschaft hat
sich allerdings nicht seinem umfeld
angepasst und hat auch nur was kurzes an
also ich würde sagen der linke stirbt
safe zuerst einerseits hat der junge in
der schneelandschaft einen vorteil er
kann sich bewegen und sich somit
versuchen warm zu highlights ist er mit
seinen shorts schlechter an die umgebung
angepasst als sein kollege in der wüste
letztlich hat der junge in der wüste
allerdings einen entscheidenden vorteil
auch in der wüste kühlen die
temperaturen nachts meistens extrem ab
also ich hatte es richtig aber mit der
komplett falsche begründung dennoch
hatte ich es richtig und bin also einen
meister anders stellt nämlich das
heutige video ist allerdings auch
beenden meine damen und herren wenn es
euch gefallen hat er das gerne einen
daumen hoch bei diesem video hat ja ich
habe mehr als die hälfte der rätsel
schaffen können ich weiß nicht wie sieht
es mit euch aus schreibt mir gern und in
die kommentare wie viele punkte
gesammelt habt 210 main kanal und nicht
abonniert haben dann klickt unter dem
video game auf abonnieren
das ist kostenlos und wenn ihr noch auf
die glocke klickt dann bekommt ihr
benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen und hey das ist echt
toll
[Musik]